bonsoir Le Journal de la rédaction
toujours en direct à 18h nous allons
faire le tour de l'actualité locale
voici sans plus attendre quelques-uns
des titres que nous allons à développer
au cours de la prochaine demi-heure le
maire sortant UMP de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et début de sa
campagne pour les municipales Alexis
Viet affrontera notamment son ancienne
adjointe comment à bord-t-il cette
situation aux airs de déjà-vu un gantier
versaillé à recréé le gang que portait
Marie-Antoinette 36 paires seulement ont
été fabriquées des gants parfumés les
élèves du lycée Marie Curie à Versailles
prépare avec leur enseignant d'EPS à un
trail nocturne d'anversize ils seront en
plateau ce soir pour nous présenter la
deuxième édition le 7 décembre du vers
trail
du jour donc pour débuter l'ouverture ce
mercredi de one nation Paris c'est aux
Clayes-sous-Bois après un an de travaux
le centre commercial dédié au luxe à
prix discount à accueilli ses premiers
clients dès 10h l'architecte Grégoire
genou était présent pour savourer ce
lancement toutes les enseignes ne sont
pas encore prêtes les derniers ouvriers
sont en train de finaliser l'ensemble
une petite période de rodage et donc à
prévoir mais qu'en pense d'ores et déjà
les premiers clients voici quelques-unes
de leur réponse au micro de Jonathan
Willmann ce matin
c'est formidable moi je on est enchanté
en anglais d'arriver c'est magnifique
très jolie magnifique oui j'espère que
ça va ça va fonctionner et le nombre de
magasins et puis le les comment
dirais-je les marques etc quoi c'est
très intéressant
ça a l'air très joli mais alors deuxième
impression il fait très froid
alors bon je veux bien mais et quand il
va pleuvoir des cordes je ne sais
vraiment pas ce qui va se passer je
pense que le fait d'avoir tout ça là à
côté de la maison c'est super bah je
l'ai vu sortir de je l'ai vu sortir de
terre en fait et là je vois qu'ils ont
fait ça à l'arrache à la fin quoi mais
c'est sympa je pense que ça va ramener
c'est nouveau en tous les cas et tout ce
qui est nouveau ça attire tout le temps
les gens
voilà pour vos réactions ce matin dans
ce nouveau centre commercial à ciel
ouvert le Conseil représentatif des
associations noires de France et le
groupe de réflexion républiciers
diversité elle vient de dévoiler un
baromètre en mesurant la contribution
des 50 villes de France à la lutte
contre le racisme politique interne
politique publique également ont été
analysés Versailles figure à la 48e
place sur 50 la ville ne lutterait pas
assez contre le racisme c'est la
conclusion de cette enquête pas de
réaction officielle pour l'instant du
côté de la municipalité politique
toujours un jour sans fin se pourrait
être le slogan de campagne d'Alexis le
Bretonneux le maire sortant UMP se
présente une nouvelle fois aux élections
municipales et une nouvelle fois il doit
faire face à la candidature d'un ancien
adjoint Alexis Viet vient de lancer sa
campagne lors d'une réunion publique en
présence de Valérie Pécresse le weekend
dernier
qu'est-ce qui motive c'est d'abord
l'équipe que j'ai autour de moi qui a
souhaité continuer et que je sois encore
alors leur leader
le maire sortant Alexis biais entouré de
son équipe pour lancer sa nouvelle
campagne électorale à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux mais qui doit
malgré tout compter avec la défection de
son ancienne premier adjointe Alexandra
Rosetti n'a pas souhaité poursuivre avec
celui qui Brigitte aujourd'hui un 4e
mandat elle critique bilan et méthodes
et se présentera face à lui en mars avec
peut-être le soutien de l'UDI je suis
tout à fait déçu de son attitude je
pense que
elle le portera en elle
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours et je pense
que les vicinois ne se laisseront pas du
paix par un volte-face comme ça de
dernière minute une situation aux airs
de déjà-vu en 2001 et il s'était fait
souffler les charpentes tricolore par le
numéro 3 de sa liste avant l'annulation
du scrutin et en 2008 un autre adjoint
avait fait campagne contre lui
l'histoire se répète mais n'inquiète pas
la chef de fil de l'UMP dans le
département Valérie Pécresse venue
apporter son soutien officiellement lors
de ce meeting malgré tout elle durcit le
ton face au centriste moi je suis en
train de négocier avec l'UDI un accord
départemental
de situations
Homer sortant UMP et Homer sortant de
l'UDI si cet accord est signé il est
bien évident que l'investiture de l'UDI
devra aller à Alexis Biet je le souhaite
je le demandais aux autorités de l'UDI
je crois pas que l'UDI intérêt à
cautionner des listes dissidentes face à
des mères qui ont l'investiture et qui
repartent parmi les projets exposés par
le candidat Biet lors de cette réunion
répondre aux besoins des plus jeunes et
des plus âgés en matière de logement ou
encore donner à la ville une salle de
spectacle d'envergure il précise tout de
même que le prochain mandat devrait être
économe
et puis et puis la droite se réagit à la
publication du nouveau découpage des
cantons nous en parlions la semaine
dernière de ces modifications à attendre
dans l'optique de ces prochaines
élections locales en 2015 moins de
cantons 21 contre 39 et donc des
regroupements de communes qui sont
largement commentés au conseil général
lors de la dernière séance le groupe
majoritaire de droite les pies ensemble
pour les Yvelines à évoqué en découpage
grossier et qui permet de ne jamais
associer des conseillers généraux
socialistes entre eux les bastions
électeurs aux voisins favorables
socialistes ont été systématiquement
ajoutés au canton de leurs élus
dénonce-t-il ils demandent que la
nouvelle délimitation s'appuie plutôt
sur les intercommunalités existantes
rappelons que le découpage concerne
l'ensemble des départements français
l'objectif pour le gouvernement et de
rendre les cantons plus cohérents en
termes démographique
pour la quatrième année la PF mette en
place des ateliers artistiques avec une
nouveauté cette année l'atelier
cartonnage l'occasion pour les
participants de garder un lien social de
sortir de chez eux tout en développant
leur esprit créatif comme l'on
constatait constater sur place yolen
Torres et le 10 mois
on travaille avec la bouche et la main
en même temps
chaque mardi à l'Association des
Paralysés de France rire et bavardages
rythme l'atelier cartonnage Lore et
Varda se connaissent depuis 30 ans elles
sont les bouts en train du groupe alors
où l'on parle de projet de loi et de
rencontres sur le thème de l'autonomie
Varda nous livre son expérience il y a
plein de choses encore qui ne sont pas
adaptées aux arrivées à un distributeur
vous savez s'il y a un rayon de soleil
vous êtes comme ça parce que vous
n'arrivez pas à taper votre code donc
bah ouais donc à chaque fois vous êtes
obligé quand même dépendre de quelqu'un
si vous voulez retirez de l'argent il
faut demander à quelqu'un d'autre mais
les distributeurs automatiques ils sont
pas adaptés on peut pas tout adapter à
l'handicap mais au moins faire un
minimum Varda a eu la poliomyélite à
l'âge de deux ans elle se déplace
aujourd'hui en béquille ou en fauteuil
et conduit une voiture adaptée Françoise
elle aussi est paralysée suite à ce
virus le village de 14 ans lorsqu'elle a
arrêté son métier de technicienne de
laboratoire et la senti le besoin
d'occuper ses journées et d'adhérer à
l'association quand on est en train de
faire des choses on n'est pas en train
de penser et de ressasser quoi que ce
soit donc puis ça permet de montrer
qu'on est capable de faire des choses
comme tout le monde
l'Association des Paralysés de France
compte 380 membres dans les Yvelines 10
ateliers sont proposés aux personnes en
situation de handicap mais aussi aux
valides cet atelier de cartonnage est
mis en place depuis deux mois pour
Christine la responsable c'est un
véritable plaisir ce sont des gens qui
se prennent jamais et pourtant ils
auraient de quoi c'est
et puis c'est sympathique enfin je veux
dire on a il y a une entraide il y a une
convivialité qu'on trouve pas partout de
quoi changer certains regards parfois
négatifs sur le handicap les handicapés
sont gays savent s'habiller ça brille et
ça peut sortir et savent s'amuser ils
ont des amis ils ont une vie tout à fait
normale
on passe à présent à la culture compte
compteur et continuent ce sont donnés
rendez-vous pendant trois jours au
Théâtre de La Grange à Bois-d'Arcy des
spectacles ou l'art de la parole se
mêlent aux arts de la musique et du
théâtre Les Contes du qui mono présenter
dimanche par exemple on transportait
elle l'imaginaire des enfants aux portes
du monde mystérieux de la lointaine Asie
Aurélia Debussy
accompagné de son couteau une citargar
japonaise et souskochida souligne
délicatement la rencontre de la musique
et du théâtre à travers trois contes
traditionnels venus de la Chine et du
Japon les contes du kimono évoquent le
monde magique et poétique de l'Asie
c'est un compte où on a essayé de tisser
avec les secours la musique à
l'intérieur du texte aussi
c'est pas juste musique compte musique
c'est quelque chose qui est très présent
il y a la musique pour la mère
on peut le rêve une belle fille
la musique pour la mort la mort la mort
ça permet aussi d'initier
le public à cette musique
en justement en l'instinct comme ça par
petite dose quand c'est approprié au
congre ça soutient la dynamique du
compte et je trouve que c'est enfin
c'est très beau une invitation à la
méditation on voyage où l'on peut même
apprendre quelques notions de japonais
les enfants c'est les amuse beaucoup
d'entendre un mot un objet ça s'appelle
comme ça en japonais et mémorise souvent
ils ont mémorisé quelques mots en
japonais je trouve que c'est ça permet
l'ouverture c'est amusant
était un vieil homme bon loyal
travailleur mais il était aussi fatigué
très fatiguée par toutes ces années j'ai
découvert l'instrument j'ai découvert
des histoires les décors comment elle
racontait et là où la musique la pureté
des sentiments
l'émotion
la beauté des gestes
c'est ce que j'ai aimé le plus
avant que le parfum ne soit posé sur la
peau et l'imprégner les gants à la cour
royale un gantier a recréer le gant que
portait Marie-Antoinette 36 paires
seulement ont été fabriqués et ils ont
bien sûr été présentés à Versailles
approchez-vous et respirez vous ne
sentez rien c'est normal les odeurs ne
passent pas la télévision dans ce gant
en agneau pourtant se cache des capsules
de tags qui contiennent du parfum pas
n'importe quel parfum celui que portait
Marie-Antoinette il y avait différents
parfumeurs qui existaient dans certains
qui étaient accrédités que pour la reine
dans un fenêtre elle utilisait beaucoup
de fleurs douces mais elle émet quand
même un petit peu d'acidité dans la
fleur et alors elle travaillait beaucoup
sur la rose Ce gant on le doit donc à
Olivier Fabre gantier depuis quatre
générations à Millau et installées
depuis peu à Versailles on a cherché un
modèle de gants que porter mariée
Antoinette en l'occurrence celui-ci donc
ce modèle de gants en fait avait été
vendu aux enchères en 2005 et puis on a
fait aussi un modèle prestige le modèle
Trianon qui est un modèle plus long et
sur lequel on a fait un motif d'un petit
panier avec beaucoup de roses on sait en
fait
euh inspiré d'une robe que porter la
reine et donc on a on a fait ce gant ce
gant est entièrement fait à la main
c'est à dire qu'il faut à peu près 4 à 5
jours pour fabriquer une paire en
broderie uniquement un vrai retour aux
sources quand on sait que le parfum
était d'abord utilisé dans les gants
Catherine de Médicis la première lui a
donné ses lettres de noblesse sous Louis
XIV il y a eu la l'ordonnance des
maîtres Gandhi parfumeurs et donc cette
ordonnance en fait permettait à
certaines personnes de d'avoir pignon
sur rue avec des boutiques et tous les
parfums à l'intérieur qui étaient
uniquement sur les gants et quelques
poudres et quelques huiles et c'est que
sous Louis XV que on est arrivé sur le
parfum pour la peau 36 paires de gants
ont été réalisées pour cette occasion
les gants parfumés de Marie-Antoinette
ont déjà presque tous trouvé la main qui
les portera
l'an dernier ils étaient près de 200 à
participer à la première édition du
vertreil entrail de nuit à Versailles
piloté par des enseignants du lycée
Marie Curie de la ville et également par
des élèves nouvelle édition à suivre ce
samedi 7 décembre sur ce plateau Fabien
combat l'usine bonsoir professeur de PS
dans cet établissement bonsoir également
à Nolwenn Villy bonsoir et Corentin kiné
vous êtes deux élèves de cet
établissement et vous participez à la
mise en place de ce vers trail on va
revenir sur la naissance du projet
forcément et puis surtout sur le fait
d'avoir réussi à le pérenniser parce que
c'est la deuxième édition c'était
l'objectif dès le départ exactement donc
c'est un objectif de pérennisation mais
avec une génération nouvelle on garde
des élèves de seconde
qui découvre ce projet on s'est dit que
pour eux ça allait être un peu plus
facile parce qu'ils allaient reprendre
la suite de leur camarades de l'année
dernière et finalement tout est reparti
à zéro on avait rasé le site web
on a quand même gardé une bonne partie
du parcours qu'on a légèrement modifié
parce que c'est une compétition sportive
on va juste le rappeler ce vers trail et
le but c'est que les élèves s'impliquent
dans l'élaboration aussi bien du
parcours que dans la communication
également c'est ça l'objectif c'est de
faire vraiment s'impliquer de A à Z
exactement avec mon collègue Xavier
Garcin
qui n'a pas pu être présent ce soir nous
avons décidé de les manager uniquement
mais ce sont eux qui font toutes les
démarches mairie conseil général au
Christ National des Forêts
validation des parcours création du
parcours trouver le matériel des
sponsors la rubalisé ils vont peut-être
vous en parler c'est très technique de
la rubalis qui se voilait la nuit voilà
des tas de démarches ou quand ils ont un
souci on revient vers eux s'ils avancent
pas assez secoue un peu les élèves c'est
une vraie éducation citoyenne autour des
métiers du sport mais on voit les images
de l'édition de l'an dernier l'objectif
c'est de les rendre plus autonome c'est
bien ça exactement et puis surtout
plutôt que de faire un cours
traditionnel sur les heures
d'enseignement d'exploration d'EPS en
alterne un peu de pratique physique mais
surtout une découverte concrète de tout
corps de métier qu'on pourrait coucher
parce qu'on fait des démarches auprès
des gens impliquées finalement autour de
l'événementiel sportif alors on va leur
poser la question est-ce que vous êtes
plus autonome aujourd'hui ça a été
difficile cette découverte cet
apprentissage pour tout mener de A à Z
on va commencer avec avec Corentin toi
ton rôle c'était le parcours c'était le
parcours et les sponsors donc oui ça a
été difficile mais c'était une
expérience assez sympa on a on est tous
très impliqué et je pense que cette
année ça va bien se passer tu as entendu
parler de l'opération déjà l'an dernier
oui oui et alors tu as eu envie de t'es
impliqué
j'étais content mais on a quand même
fait pas mal de choses je pensais que ça
allait être plus facile que ça qu'est-ce
qui était le plus dur c'est le parcours
et aussi trouver les sponsors parce que
quand il nous répondent pas faut
relancer tout le temps et ça a été
compliqué pas forcément la meilleure
période en plus pour aller chercher des
sponsors et demander des sous aux
entreprises c'était pas forcément la
tâche la plus évidente Nolwenn c'était
autour de la communication alors ça
consistait en quoi depuis et puis ça a
commencé quand aussi dès le début de
l'année dès la rentrée bah il a fallu
que je trouve que je me mette en contact
avec le journaliste de Versailles donc
j'ai eu le droit à une interview pour
qu'il fasse un article sur le projet et
en fait il fallait surtout que les gens
soient informés donc c'était un moyen
d'informer un peu le plus de coureurs
possible et de rendre le projet le plus
intéressant possible pour le plus grand
nombre de participants et ça prend
beaucoup de temps en dehors de des
heures de cours est-ce qu'il faut s'y
impliquer aussi régulièrement on a eu
l'occasion d'y aller quand même
plusieurs fois en forêt sur le parcours
on y a quand même passé
un sacré un sacré bout de temps je
pourrais pas vous dire exactement mais
c'est vrai que on a des fois eu été
obligé de louper certains cours pour y
mettre encore plus de coeur c'est sûr
mais oui c'est vraiment on est quand
même une trentaine d'élèves à participer
à ce projet donc c'est quand même
un certain nombre et on s'implique comme
on peut donc on se libère et puis tout
le monde y met du coeur donc ça marche
bien vos collègues sont satisfaits de
voir que les élèves ne viennent pas pour
pouvoir participer à votre projet ça se
passe bien dans l'établissement d'un
produit effectivement il faut annoncer
les choses assez tôt il faut parfois
aussi penser informer des familles dans
les bons délais
c'est pas un moment de manière
exceptionnelle mais par exemple ce
vendredi veille de la course ils
arrêtaient cours à 14h 14h à la nuit
tombante on fait du balisage samedi il
viendront dès 9h du matin jusque 21h ils
vont être pareil sur la fin de
l'organisation ils ont créé un vrai
organigramme avec leur propre mission
retrait des dossards ravitaillement
consigne site web ils ont tous un peu
leur mission donc ils avaient une
commande chaque semaine mais satisfait
du résultat de ce qu'ils ont produit
comme travail on est très heureux on est
on est relativement fier d'eux avec mon
collègue mais on sait que le plus dur
reste à venir maintenant il faut que ce
soit samedi soir après la ligne
d'arrivée franchie que les coureurs
soient heureux que les couleurs ne se
perdent pas et que il y ait une vraie
ambiance chaleureuse alors combien
d'inscrits à peu près 200 l'an dernier
la cette année vous êtes à combien ça va
se dérouler comment
on est déjà à 200 inscrits donc on a
encore jusqu'à demain soir pour
peut-être finaliser et augmenter le
nombre de coureurs mais on est déjà
assez fier du nombre de participants le
site web qui va s'afficher vous pouvez
bien évidemment aller vous renseigner
pour ne pas vous inscrire justement à
cette à cette opération le parcours
c'est un parcours sportif c'est un trail
peut-être rappeler puisque tu t'es
occupé du parcours ce qu'est un trail et
puis les particularités parce que c'est
semi nocturne il va falloir courir avec
une lampe torche oui tout à fait alors
le départ est à la nuit tombante à 17h30
et le parcours se fait entièrement dans
la forêt de Porchefontaine donc avec un
dénivelé positif d'à peu près 400 mètres
donc il y a de belles montées sportif
toi-même sportif oui j'ai fait le parc
c'est difficile c'est difficile c'est
très long
toujours là ils vont courir la nuit donc
c'est encore plus compliqué je pense
pour eux mais après c'est tous ceux qui
veulent courir je pense qu'ils sont
fiers de courir dans la nuit c'est
quelque chose d'unique donc c'est une
bonne chose à faire
un petit peu le parcours de Corentin
Corentin et vient d'assez loin dans
notre lycée c'est un élève qui a une
autorisation de dérogation de cartes
scolaire parce qu'il est dans notre
section sportive de triathlon donc lui
il a travaillé sur le parcours en
courant mais aussi en VTT lors des
entraînements de la section sportive et
il aura un vrai rôle vendredi et samedi
c'est que il va gérer comme un
professeur avec une partie de ses
camarades le balisage d'une partie de
4,5 km de la forêt comme notre camarade
de la section sportive et comme mon
collègue et moi-même pour ceux qui ont
fait juste le parcours l'an dernier
est-ce qu'il y a des nouveautés sur le
parcours pour ceux qui hésitent
peut-être à s'inscrire s'il recherche la
nouveauté il y a des changements la
grande nouveauté c'est un aspect très
convivial c'est que au bout de 4,5 km on
va retraverser la halte d'athlétisme qui
est la zone couverte de l'épreuve ou le
public nous attend chaleureusement et
quelques modifications de single dans la
forêt voilà je pense que c'est un
parcours très attrayant la grosse
nouveauté aussi cette année c'est qu'on
va avoir deux équipages complètement
spécifiques de jeunes enfants handicapés
je pense que Corentin peut vous en dire
un petit peu plus à ce sujet je t'en
prie Corentin c'est une association qui
s'appelle Les Dunes ne l'espoir qui nous
prête de girouettes avec deux enfants
handicapés qui vont faire entièrement la
course pour être autonome donc c'était
un projet
en plus de toute l'organisation
et donc ce sera à découvrir le coup
d'envoi de la course et 17h 17h30
exactement 17h30 si vous souhaitez
encore vous inscrire c'est possible
qu'est-ce qu'on gagne il faut vendre la
course vendre la course c'est toi qui
aura le mot de la fin de l'OM
d'avoir fini la course même malgré le
classement après on est encore plus fier
selon le classement mais juste d'avoir
participé c'est le principal et c'est
une bonne course à faire donc venez le
plus nombreux qu'à tout compris regarde
la caméra pour vendre la course c'est
parfait merci beaucoup à vous deux merci
également à votre enseignant d'être venu
sur ce plateau et puis on reviendra sur
cette compétition dans nos prochaines
éditions merci à tous les trois on reste
dans le domaine du sport avec plaisir
qui accueillait ce week-end une manche
régionale de cerf-volant acrobatique la
discipline compte quelques 300 licenciés
en France dont le jeune champion
d'Europe Julien elle aille Annie
licencier aux ailes de plaisir donc un
club hyvelinois nous avons levé les yeux
pour suivre sa chorégraphie Anthony Rech
Julien Layani découvre le cerf-volant
lors d'une rencontre internationale à
Berck au bout de quelques heures de
pratique sur la plage il ne veut plus
quitter le ciel des yeux autodidacte des
acrobaties dans les airs Julien a vite
compris qu'il fallait savoir faire
preuve de patience pour maîtriser ce vol
tout en douceur c'est un sport qui
demande beaucoup de temps parce que si
on veut apprendre une nouvelle figure si
on veut se perfectionner
ça se fait pas en un clin d'œil je veux
dire il y a pas de pas réellement de
méthode miracle donc on est obligé de
travailler un petit peu tout seul ou
d'aller demander puisqu'il y a pas
vraiment de pas vraiment de cours en
fait donc il faut un peu s'initier tout
seul de mémoire de cerveau liste à 18
ans Julien est le plus jeune champion
d'Europe de l'histoire de la discipline
les ailes de son cerf-volant entre les
mains le plaisir roi maîtrise à la
perfection ce ballet plein d'émotions le
temps d'un instant son aigle de toile
épouse les notes de musique avec une
légèreté déconcertante
une chorégraphie ponctuée de
renversement au milieu des nuages mais
qui est dépendant de la météo
c'est vrai que avoir du soleil avoir un
vent régulier c'est quand même après ça
après on peut quand même pratiquer le
cerveau lampe dans des conditions très
difficiles donc même si il pleut s'ils
vont être très forts aussi les très
faibles alors il y a des limites en
compétition compétition c'est 4 4 km/h
en minimum 45 en maximum
Julien se classe finalement troisième de
la manche régionale de plaisir la
discipline compte quelques 300 licenciés
en France dont une cinquantaine ça donne
à la compétition
et on part pour la Floride à présent
avec ces images que vous allez découvrir
Floride où se trouve romain des traits
yvelinois qui participa des épreuves qui
lui ouvriront peut-être les portes de
l'Espace il est l'un des lauréats d'un
concours international une grande marque
déodorant il a déjà gagné le droit avec
une vingtaine d'autres à travers le
monde de suivre ce stage sur cette base
d'entraînement et vendredi on sera
lesquels d'entre eux pourront se rendre
dans l'espace puisque c'est un concours
il est encore des sélections ce sera en
tout cas une première pour des civils
français nous avons eu un Romain en
ligne le planning est très serré pour
tous ces candidats là ce sont les
Français que vous avez vu à l'image il y
a d'ailleurs un autre évier noir parmi
eux un planning très serré mais tout se
passe bien et nous essaierons d'établir
la liaison avec Romain demain en direct
rendez-vous des 18 heures pour une
nouvelle édition du journal toutes nos
précédentes éditions sont à consulter en
replay sur notre site internet vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
excellente soirée